Welcome Ben and Erin Napier.
(crowd cheers)
What's up?
Hey Drew
I've been like your biggest fan since
my whole life, basically.
So this is a really big moment for me.
(laughs)
No really.
I didn't know this.
When I was in high school I want it to be you Mad Love.
You're kind of rocking the hair I have to say.
Yup and I cut it very short when I went to college.
Which is when I noticed.
Yes, Ben really loved my short hair.
And that's why he noticed me.
And I was just trying to beat your beard.
So anyway.
Also our three year old Helen, is obsessed with ET.
Oh
And I know she's very excited.
ET is everything to Helen.
Yeah. You're you're part of our life every day.
And she's planning to marry Elliott when she grows up.
Yeah. I had a crush on him too
but he was like my brother.
And that was just weird.
And I mean, it's so funny that you would say I'm
in your home because that is what you guys, you know
the word home is in your show title.
And there's so much meaning behind the word home.
Yeah. It's a, it's an incredible thing.
And it's an incredible honor that we get to help
so many people found their first home.
Find a transitional home.
Find there, you know, their last home, their forever home.
We, we love what we do.
We do.
And we are extreme more extreme than Ben.
I'm an extreme homebody home is everything.
And that's the thing.
When I'm designing a home on hometown
I'm always thinking if I were the person who lived here
what would make me long for it when I'm away from it.
And like, that is what home is.
It's not how perfect and pretty
and Pinterest worthy your house is.
It's so much more than that.
Everything you said, just it totally encapsulates why
I think you guys are so successful.
And so I think your philosophy is what connects with people
and makes you, you know, the success that you are
and connect to people the way you do.
Because if you go into their home with that intention
that translates that transfers.
I hope so.
That's the only way I know how to do this.
And it's, you know, it's, there are things like
you know, pretty paint colors, pretty, you know
sofas and things.
And you know, we can, we can help you find that that's
that's the easy part of it.
The hard part of our job is getting to know the homeowners
and then figuring out, okay, what makes this person tick?
What makes them want to be, you know, at home.
What can we do to this house?
Yes, we're going to make it beautiful
but we want it to be theirs.
Personal.
Personal over pretty.
That's always our concern.
No, you guys met in college, right?
And you were in, you were getting a degree in fine arts
Erin and Ben were getting a degree in history.
How did that affect like your design
and how what's the rear view mirror of like your intention
of what you wanted to learn in college
and how it applies to this amazing life you're living now?
I think so, like, for me, it's easy to point out.
Like I studied history
and I love the history of these houses.
I love, you know, researching it and getting to know it
and learning how, how craftspeople do things, you know
a hundred years ago, 150 years ago.
And, you know, trying to implement that into what we do.
You have a real reference for what the house was.
Yes and how it became that.
And how we can maintain the heart
and soul of what it was originally.
Yeah, and then also, but also like who lived there
and what, what their life was like and how
they affected this incredible town that we get to live in.
But then from your point of view, we've often said
that Erin, so Erin used to have a stationery company
and it was internationally successful.
She sold stationary all
over the world and it was incredible.
And she's always said
that designing wedding stationary is the same thing
as designing somebodies house.
You just have to figure out.
Yeah you're just saving people's hearts.
You're taking their personalities
their past and their love.
And you're putting it into something visual.
Its the exact same thing either.
Yeah.
Do you have like little, like things that you're just like
these are non-negotiables, these are rules.
We have, like, I always want to do curtains
at least a foot out from either side of the windows set
that the fabric doesn't cover the windows.
Like when you Mount
do you have like little pet peeves and things you must do.
I have a hang up about base boards.
I was going to says that was yours.
And I think that obviously comes from like an art school.
When you mat a piece of art
you have more space at the bottom.
Like the bottom of a mat is usually one inch taller
at the top, but visually it looks equal.
Anyway. Baseboards just make a room look balanced
to me and you need a big one.
I think that that's our big thing, like as designers.
I consider myself to be a furniture designer
but it's...
For us it's about balance.
So like, if you're building, if you walk into a room
and you see a table and it's got big thick, chunky legs
and then a really thin top, it doesn't look right.
It's like something about it just irks me a little bit.
Yes.
I, I feel like I'm at the front row
of my favorite themes of life, which is design.
(cheerful music)